i cannot
neglect to mention this story uh some
topless pro-abortion feminists protested
during a wnba game last night protested
over abortion
um
i think it was very nice of them to
stage this protest in a forum where
nobody would see it
and
now we're going to see it though because
i'm going to play it so let's let's play
some of the footage of this go ahead and
play it
when they are running running around the
court
no shirt on
security tracking down
someone took a tumble there
that is uh i gotta say that's the most
athleticism
i've ever seen on a wnba court
mostly because i've never seen a wnba
court
i didn't even know they played on a
chord that's the honest truth i thought
that they just played they picked
somebody's driveway for each game and
they played there i didn't that's great
that's a good job uh ladies you get a
whole court to yourself i mean literally
get it to yourself you know because no
one's there um
it was pretty rude of the protesters
honestly i mean the fan in the audience
didn't pay to see that
actually he really didn't pay to see it
he paid to see an imagine dragon's
concert and went to the wrong stadium
and then was kind of stuck there for
what i understand according to reports
um
i've read actually that uh this is
interesting that after that disruption
that they decided not to start the game
back up uh because the ref said there's
just no point you know and plus he was
hungry and wanted to eat dinner and so
they just kind of ended it
didn't matter anyway it's a wnba game so
anyway
that's what happened there well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt well
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content